while california brings the hammer down
on struggling businesses that defy these
coveted mandates
they're letting convicted felons get
away with murder
and i mean literally last week in orange
county superior court ordered the county
to reduce its jail population
by 50 to allow for social distancing
among inmates
according to orange county sheriff don
barnes this ruling would force
the release of dozens of prisoners
serving time for murder
child molestation and domestic violence
oh goody
sheriff barnes joins me now sheriff do
you intend to comply with this order
i do not intend to comply with the order
we tend to uh we're going to appeal the
order
to the california appellate court i
think the order is very overreaching
in its how broad it is and in essence we
don't really have low-level offenders
remaining in orange county jail we've
already released all them so these are
very serious offenders that we're
looking at
being ordered to release the recidivism
rate
among orange county inmates released
early due to the pandemic
is up 44
for those inmates so sheriff it's clear
this is this is a serious public threat
as if californians don't have enough to
deal with uh
so how how could a judge knowing just
the recidivism
part of the equation in good conscience
have approved releasing even more
criminals
well those are the low level offenders
that we've been releasing that are
uh reoffending so you can imagine what
it would be like with much more serious
offenders
in essence this judge is is a
court-ordered crime spree that he has
issued through this order
knowing that these are very serious
offenders uh 97 of the
vote medically vulnerable are in for
murder or attempted murder 94
for child molestation and that's not
including the rest of the population
that we'd have to consider for release
so it's a significant threat sheriff i
can't remember now
what your rules are there so forgive me
but
how many of the people in jail if you
know
are in the country undocumented in your
jail right now
generally it's about 10 and because of
the laws in california i can't turn
those over to ice
unless you're a high level offender or a
very serious crime
and that was a bill that was passed into
law in 2018. yeah the sanctuary deal
right so
yes sanctuary yeah yeah that's just
fantastic so you got 10
of your jail with people who shouldn't
be there and then they want to release
almost 50 of those over there because
you're worried about the murderers and
the rapists
getting covered okay sheriff
yeah go ahead yeah it's just a very
uh i don't think it takes into
consideration the threat to the public
obviously coba is a threat to everybody
and we've had that issue in our jail we
mitigated it down to zero before we'll
do that again
but to think that you have to totally
neglect
the risk to the community i think is
quite
an absurd order i'm surprised the aclu
isn't saying that all the inmates should
get the coveted virus before
law-abiding americans that'll be next
sheriff thank you so much